from johns hopkins university however
the world health organization is
estimating the actual figure could be
almost three times higher than that
higher than the figure the health
authorities are suggesting the virus was
first identified in the chinese city of
wuhan in december of
2019 almost 250 million infections have
since been reported globally in a
statement the un secretary general
antonio guterres said this devastating
milestone remind reminds us that we are
failing much of the world while wealthy
countries are rolling out third doses of
the kobit 19 vaccine only about five
percent of people in africa are fully
vaccinated this is a global shame here's
priyanka gupta
people gasping for air
families torn apart
and governments forced to close borders
and order millions of people to be
confined to their homes
the coven 19 pandemic has now killed
more people than any other viral
epidemic in the 21st century
but almost two years since the first
case emerged in china's wuhan province
and a new coronavirus spread rapidly
across the globe effective vaccines
developed at a record pace seem to be
having some impact
at the moment
that
average number of daily deaths worldwide
is lower than what we were seeing last
year and a lot of that could be
attributed to
a combination of vaccination people
understanding how covid infects people
and what they have to do to control it
but in russia which produced the world's
first domestically developed covet-19
job many people are reluctant to take it
and that's leading to a record number of
debts
and after the initial optimism of a fast
vaccine rollout in the uk other parts of
western europe and china infections are
rising it'll be very interesting to see
what happens in in the northern
hemisphere as
uh by and large many countries have no
restrictions at all now
and vaccines are obviously the whole
population is not vaccinated and and as
they go into winter people are closing
their windows and their doors and and
there's a higher risk of transmission in
in both households and businesses and
and social social settings so
so i think we're we're about to learn a
lot um
and that is how much we can rely on the
vaccine
while richer nations are racing to give
booster shots poor countries
particularly in africa are struggling to
get supplies of vaccines
leaving millions of people vulnerable
conflict and poverty have already
devastated health care systems in syria
yemen haiti and the democratic republic
of congo which have yet to vaccinate
even five percent of the populations the
lack of vaccination in the poor world
has a huge impact in two ways for a
start many many people are dying today
that don't need to die they're getting
very very sick and losing relatives we
still have a situation where nurses and
doctors in some of these countries are
not even protected against this killer
disease
the pandemic seems far from over
but some countries like australia
thailand and cambodia are preparing for
a new way of life
reopening their economies with more
vaccines and fewer restrictions
priyanka gupta al jazeera